a gold rush in mali's northern region
led by armed groups Al-Qaeda isil
Fighters and T Rebels control artisanal
mines Al jazer witnessed African
migrants on their way to Europe but
forced by traffickers to dig for gold
many are children working in the desert
under extremely hot conditions they
search for the precious metal a small
nugget that will be sold on the
international Market from the desert of
Mali to the jewelry shops in Europe the
Middle East and
Asia we've been here for a Year my
brother has been here for almost 6
months we are provided with Safety and
Security as long as we do the work the
UN office on drugs and crimes has put
out this map showing all the gold mining
sites in the Sahel most are under the
control of armed groups in 2021 $13
billion worth of gold was produced from
these sites
non-state armed groups they want to
replace in the long term the state so
they stay there and that when you want
to replace the state what you do you
have to fund your operations with a lot
of things run some uh trafficking in
persons and gold trafficking the report
states that un planes from mali's
peacekeeping Mission known as minusma
were used to smuggle gold from the
northern city of kidal to the capital
bamako we reached out to ma but they
have declined to comment on the report
Mali Juna have asked the UN peacekeeping
Force to leave the country including
from the northern bases stepping in
aralan forces and Russian mercenaries
from the Vagner group last week the
country's Juna signed an agreement with
Russia to build the biggest gold
refinery in West Africa I think Mali is
now realizing that they were losing 95 %
of their potential revenue is trying to
uh you know take control of of the
territory which means that that will
have a a bubble effect in the
displacement of those these Not
non-state actors Rights group describ
gold in Mali as a blood mineral fueling
conflict the northern Frontier is set to
become a fierce Battleground for a
precious metal to the world that malians
are dying for Nicholas Hawk Al jazer
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer